und wenn die das nicht haben dann gibt
es dicke beschwerde mehr aber eine ganz
dick und das ist jetzt wirklich so das
erste mal wo ich sage wollt ihr mich
verarschen und herzlich willkommen bei
einem neuen video ja ich hoffe natürlich
geht es gut weil wir auf jeden fall
super wetter heute also was er kann es
eigentlich nicht sein ich weiß wieder
ziemlich lange in köln da war das wetter
jetzt am ende nicht so gut ist wenn ich
wieder hier hingefahren und zack sieht
es gut aus also ich bin alt gerade bei
meinen eltern ich weiß nicht ob es jeder
von euch gesehen hat wie gut man muss
auch sagen nein das hat nicht jeder
gesehen von allen die mich abonniert hat
aber das ist ja fast nie so trotzdem ist
das video echt gut angekommen und viele
haben geschrieben alex macht das doch
bitte mal es ging nämlich letzte woche
um neue mcdonald's produkte bzw
mcdonald's produkte die fast niemand
kennt halt weil sie so neu ist also das
habe ich damals schon mal gestartet und
einfach so ein zitat gemacht und in dem
video ob ich euch gefragt ob ich das
ganze auch mal bei dem mccafé machen
sollen weil die da halt auch ein paar
neue sachen haben und keine ahnung ich
finde das macht so spaß einfach da lang
zu fahren und die sachen zu probieren
und ich weiß ja auch dass viele von euch
diese videos gerne schauen
deswegen machen wir das heute heute geht
es halt und diese ganzen neuen mac
kaffeeprodukte ich zeige euch das mal
kurz hier mccafé genau das sind
irgendwie alles neue sachen sieht man
hier kulturcafé called to als ich mag es
gerne kaffee vor allem so mit karamell
mega gut hin bärtschis cagey strings
muffin rainbow donath also bin ich mal
gespannt was das heute wird weil mit
meiner ganzen erfahrung also ich glaube
man kann mich mittlerweile schon so als
expertin abstempeln es gibt dann ja gut
vielleicht auch nicht auf jeden fall
gibt es dann immer eine bewertung von
mir zu jedem produkt von 0 bis 10
und ja ich bin gespannt also sozusagen
auf geht's ins auto wir fahren los und
mal schauen ob es lecker wird
da hat wohl jemand heute heiraten ist es
in eurer stadt auch normal dass die
immer hupen wenn jemand heiratet
wahrscheinlich ne leute ich muss sagen
ich bin gerade wirklich mal gespannt ob
ich bin also entweder das sind jetzt die
gleichen oder das ist die nächste
hochzeit aber ich glaube das sind die
gleichen hauptsache stabiles auto auf
jeden fall bin ich mal gespannt ob ich
im dorf überhaupt diese ganzen mccafé
produkte kriege so in köln bei mir gar
kein problem
die machen das ob das überall so ist
weiß ich nicht und ich hoffe auch dass
sie alles haben was ich haben will wenn
ich ein bisschen scheiße weil dann kann
ich das video heute vergessen weil hier
gibt's zu diesem mcdonald's bei mir
offen dort na ja wenn die am gegründet
jetzt wird sie grün wir sehen uns gleich
kann man hier auch die mccafé produkte
bestellen ja dann hätte ich gerne einmal
den kuka roboter wahnsinnig habe ich im
internet gesehen also das steht dass man
den dann zusammen mit diesem rennen
daytona bestellen könnt mccafé du okay
sechseinhalb stunden später auch das
haben sie mit ok oh dann nehme ich
einfach nur einen ersten kleinen fail
also ich dachte wirklich dass sie hier
noch mehr kaffee haben weil das hatten
die mal aber die habe umgebracht oder so
keine ahnung so oft bin ich auch nicht
mehr
deswegen fahren wir jetzt in die nächste
großstadt ich habe mir jetzt mal
netterweise so eine kleine fanta hier
mitgenommen weil ich wollte auch dann so
nicht gar nichts bestellen
geht das überhaupt keine ahnung ich weiß
in die nächste stadt und da soll es wohl
in mekka vergeben so weit ich weiß wir
sehen uns dann da wieder so leute
nächster versuch das sieht schon mal
besser aus hallo
sie haben ja auch mehr kaffee oder ich
hätte gerne einmal gold trug aramäer
latte
dann alkohol kaffee ach so haben sie
nicht dieses callthrough karamell okay
ja da nehme ich einfach nur das ja das
war die leute das gibt's doch nicht oder
ohne spaß dieser macdonald star der
hatten bei kaffee steht zumindest im
internet aber die hatten absolut keinen
plan was ich meine jetzt habe ich schon
zwei sachen von zwei unterschiedlichen
läden die ich eigentlich gar nicht
wollte ja gut okay ich habe jetzt noch
ein rausgesucht der dritte der ist jetzt
noch mal 20 kilometer entfernt von mir
und wenn die das nicht haben dann gibt
es eine dicke beschwerden aber eine ganz
dicke
ich habe mit dem mcdonalds marketing
nämlich wirklich nah und münchen zurück
vor ein zwei jahren hatte ich eigentlich
auch eine kooperation mit denen die ist
dann allerdings geplatzt wenn ich jetzt
gar nicht weiter eingehen aber das war
schon da dachte ich so schade aber wenn
ihr das so sehen dann gab es heute nicht
mehr also gefallen es zu dem nächsten
und ich hoffe dass wir etwas drückt mir
die daumen
ich muss sagen ich habe keine ahnung was
ich jetzt hier genau ist aber es
schmeckt gut
also bleibt mir gern mal den namen von
dem ding in die kommentare so leute hier
als beweis ich kann man es sehen mccafé
drive so wenn die das hier nicht haben
dann bin ich jetzt mal so sauer ich bin
jetzt 40 kilometer hier kann man auch
für mccafé bestellen kann man sich hat
gerne dieses kaltblut karamell dazu
haben sie das
muss ich reinkommen dafür ja ok ja dann
komme ich eben rein okay soweit ihr habt
es gehört ich kriege das nur wenn ich
jetzt rein gehen deswegen dass man sich
jetzt noch machen
ich bin so weit gefahren und ja ich
hoffe das klappt jetzt auch erst dachte
ich okay das wird hier wieder nicht aber
die hoffnung stirbt zuletzt
so leute nach 20 jahren geführt habe ich
jetzt wirklich das was ich haben wollte
worauf eigentlich diese video idee heute
basiert ja und zwar auf diesen neuen
mccafé produkten und das ist jetzt
wirklich so das erste mal wo ich sage
wollt ihr mich verarschen also ich bin
wirklich fast immer nur hier wenn ich
irgendwas aufnehme und dann nehme ich
das auch so ein bisschen ich weiß ich
dachte ich so bisschen mehr auf so
kleine fehler und sonstwas wobei man an
mcdonald's natürlich jetzt nicht die
größten anforderungen hat ist ja einfach
so ich meine christian menü für sieben
euro da sollte man sich nicht beschweren
trotzdem bei diesem neuen mcaffee sachen
wenn man die so schön in der werbung
darstellt und so und dann so was bei
rauskommt dann denke ich mir dicker dann
lasst es doch gleich weil das einfach
nur scheiße das problem ist ja nicht ich
habe jetzt gerade drin zehn minuten
gewartet weil von allen leuten die dort
arbeiten immer nur einer oder so
geschult ist für diese mcaffee sachen
anscheinend also so glaube ich ist das
wenn jemand von euch bei mir ganz
arbeitet und das genau aber ich schreibe
das sehr gerne in die kommentare auf
jeden fall musste ich wirklich sehr
lange warten ich habe extra dann noch
mal nachgefragt ob ich irgendwann heute
bedient werde und dann habe ich halt
diese kombi bestellt in der werbung so
aussieht
also ich dachte halt ja auch wenn das so
aussieht war schon krass ich habe es
jetzt zwar nachgebaut
so wie es eigentlich aussehen sollte und
was ich bekommen habe ist das hier ja
hier mit dem rainbow obendrauf den ich
gerade selber drauf gemacht hat man sich
dazu auf der kamera das sieht bestimmt
nicht mal schlecht aus so glaube ich gar
nicht mag nur ich weiß nicht ich dachte
halt ich kriege halt vom glas wie es
auch da stand sollte ich probiert es mal
kurz aber ich kann ich jetzt schon sagen
dass es nicht gut schmecken wird einfach
weil es mit diesem kombinierten sich
nicht gut schmecken kann
das ding ist nämlich ihr seht das ja das
teil ist voll mit eiswürfeln das
schmeckt einfach nur nach wasser der
bisher in irgendwie wasser angekippt
bisschen milch ein bisschen fertig
kaffee oder so der jemen ist mit
karamell den probiere ich auch mal kurz
und der schmeckt halt einfach noch mehr
nach wasser also das sind so zwei sachen
also ich muss natürlich sagen das hatte
ich schon sehr oft bei solchen sachen
das jetzt einfach nicht schmecken weil
die leute nicht wissen wie sie das
zubereiten das ist halt meine kritik
daran jetzt so einen anderen videos bin
ich immer selber zufrieden aber ja ich
weiß auch nicht leute die sonne knallt
häufig auf mein auto deswegen war ich
probiere es doch kurz diesen pokal schon
fertig deutlich stärker als im auto weil
die sonne so krass drauf knallt deswegen
müssen wir jetzt erst mal nach hause
fahren müssen uns gleich soweit danach
und ungefähr anderthalb stunden bin ich
auch wieder zu hause ist es so lange da
hätte ich auf keinen gedacht und vor
allem das war wirklich ein hartes video
weil ich nirgendwo diese drinks gefunden
habe die ich da bestellen wollte nach
dem zweiten habe ich erst überlegt erst
jetzt noch zu einem dritten oder nicht
eigentlich schon aufgegeben aber ich
habe es durchgezogen ach so und das habe
ich eben total vergessen zu probieren
einfach weil es so heiß im autobau und
ich will einfach noch nach hause
deswegen bringt sich jetzt entspannt
beim schneiden das ist irgendwie so ein
neuer himbeer muffin
[Musik]
also ich muss sagen der schon sehr sehr
gut menge neuen schlaganfall es gab halt
nur vier neue sachen die ich alle nicht
kannte und deswegen noch kurz die
punktebewertung also diese beiden drinks
da wirklich totale katastrophe ich weiß
ja dass bayern besser ist krieg 0 punkte
dieser rain porto hat er dann sozusagen
dazugehört kriegt 7 und dieses ding hier
kriegt neuen also leute das war's mit
einem weiteren test ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen lassen doch nach oben da
genießt das schöne wetter geht raus an
die verschluckt haut reihenfolge
instagram 30 alex w